Tàn thống á, hiện có sống sống của sân với trên hai chăm mũ viên nhận cầu, một trong phần chăm là đồng bảo sinh tập lau.
Thưa kênh chủ chương sóa nhà tạng nhà sổn á, tăng bàn có người tạng của đường khủ trở dựng nhà ở mới.
Trong đó, mùi hai hộ được cá mô trên sĩ đường viên phòng bà vị sụ trực tiếp sụb đỡ.
Những việc làm cuộc thế, nhớ tình ấy đã có phần cùng của nền tiền quảy nhân xanh vào đàn nhận nước,
khó khỏe sông đầm hình ảnh mục đợi cuộc hồ, vì cuộc sống ấm nò của nhân xanh.
Năng quá trị sống nhân tạng nhà dọn năng, thì đợi đàn nhận nước.
Và chính quy định cơm quan tâm và đợi mấy tảm nhà của trở được độn bên phòng a giúp đỡ.
Làm nhà đợi đầm bảo văn kướng cho bà con xí sống và tự tin chuyên bò đợi bà con nhân dân.
Phát triển trình trế sống hồi người mò phát triển.
Từ trường trung đúng đánh của đàn, sự vọc của quất đẹt của các ui chiến quyền để những việc làm giễ tình của bộ đợi mình phòng
và tình thần đoàn kết của nhân xanh.
Trình trình sóa nhà tạng nhà dọn nước đã thực sự đi vào cuộc sống.
Bộ kênh nhà hoàn thành là một điểm biểu phượng chắc để người xanh ăn cơ,
ím tâm lăng đậu, sản xuất, vượt lên phát nhau.